we're asked to multiply 32 point 1 2 or
32 and 12 hundredths times 0.5 or just
5/10 now when you multiply decimals you
multiply them the exact same way you
would multiply whole numbers and then
you count the number of spaces behind
the decimal you have in your two numbers
you're multiplying and you're going to
have that many spaces in your product
and let me show you what I'm talking
about so let's just multiply these two
characters so we have 32 point one two
times times 0.5 0.5 and when you write
them out you can just push both of them
all the way to the right you could
almost ignore the decimal right now you
can almost you should write the decimal
where they belong but you can almost
pretend that this is three thousand two
hundred and twelve times five and then
we'll worry about the decimals in a
second so let's get started so if we
were just multiplying 5 times three
thousand two hundred and twelve we would
say well five times two is ten regroup
the 1 5 times 1 is 5 plus 1 plus 1 is 6
5 times 2 is 10 5 times 2 is 10 regroup
the 1 and then finally you have 5 times
3 is 15 plus 1 is 16 is 16 and then we
don't have any other places this 0
really isn't if we were just doing this
as 0 5 we wouldn't multiply 0 times this
whole thing we'd just get 0 anyway so
just 5 times 3212 gives us this number
but now we want to care about the
decimals we just have to count the total
number of spaces or places we have
behind the decimal points in the two
numbers we're multiplying so we have 1 2
3 spaces or 3 numbers to the right of
the decimals and the two numbers were
worth that we're multiplying so we need
that many Speight numbers to the right
of the decimal in our answer so you go 1
2 3 put the decimal right over there
so 32.1 2 times 0.5 is 16 point 0 6 oh
and this trailing 0 right here we can
ignore because it's really not
adding any information there so we could
just write this as sixteen point zero
six now the last thing you want to do is
just kind of make sure that this makes
sense you have a number that's almost 32
and we're multiplying it by 0.5 remember
0.5 is the same thing as 5 over 10 which
is the same thing as 1/2 so we're really
multiplying 32-point 1/2 times 1/2 we're
trying to figure out what 1/2 of 32
point 1/2 is and well half of 32 is 16
and then 1/2 of 0.12 is 0.06 so this
makes complete sense